we got to see lara croft in action in
rise of the Tomb Raider and the two
women sitting on the couch here it got
to see even more so we they are the ones
we want to talk to about rise of the
Tomb Raider alexa ray corriea Mary kiss
thanks for coming on set yeah and rise
of the tomb raider lara croft his back
and like super murderous not that she
wasn't murderers and rot in Tomb Raider
come on I mean that's what she does yeah
we were I don't know we were we left the
demo we were sitting in the car in
silence and then Mary turns to me and
just says this is the most metal gear
we've ever seen Laura Croft metal gear
she straight up broke a bottle and
stabbed dudes through it with it yeah
Metal Gear was more about how you have
way more player choice you can actually
decide how you want to attack us a given
situation something that they didn't
show in that footage that we got to see
I thought was really amazing is that you
can take stuff from the environment like
mushrooms and you can make a bomb with
it you can kill some dude adhere the
bomb to his chest throw them out there
so that somebody else will inevitably
find the body be like oh my god there's
dead guy over here run over to it the
bomb goes off a poison cloud comes over
and kills that guy to give you trap
corpses it's great it's no great it's
like another level of how you want to do
it so obviously yeah you could go in
there with a gun which is how I did a
lot of it last two Raider know I always
kind of got a little bored with doing
that I don't always want to go in guns
blazing I this tomb raider is giving us
the opportunity to be really sneaky it
gives the opportunity to attack things
for different angles and i were directly
in the face was right that's how I
played to murder number one yeah that's
that's how i did it and i remember them
saying to us also that you might
remember that when you were able to
unlock character skills by the time the
game was done everyone had all the same
skills unlocked yes it was like you did
it but really all they were doing was
they were preventing you from having all
that stuff at once but by the end of the
game we all had the same Laura yeah
nothing was different well in this one
Lara's skill tree divides much wider and
the amount of stuff that you will obtain
throughout the game will not give the
ability to have everything yeah now you
can actually customize your your Lara
for the one you want they were telling
us that you could play the whole game
and not unlock everything like they have
the skills are a little bit different
there's more exploration focus skills
and then more combat focus skills and
you could choose to either I guess focus
on may be upgrading her climbing ax or
upgrading you know some her you there's
a skill where you can learn how to read
glyphs and stuff so you get that sort of
archaeal archaeological element to it so
you can either focus on one or the other
and by the time you're done like you'll
have like your Laura may be different
from like someone else's Laura because
you focused on this one thing or you
maxed out this one thing I think it
sounds really cool and certainly the
Laura we saw in this demo you know was
sort of more the pugilistic more violent
Laura but this is also like you know if
you're demoing something at Gamescom
you're not going to show oh my god I've
been running around this big open area
for like 30 minutes find all these
little things which was one of my
favorite parts of Tomb Raider and of
course that's going to be in rise of the
Tomb Raider as well let's talk a little
bit about that exploration did you see a
little bit more of that during the demo
that you saw we did we actually got a
look at the prophets tomb which is one
of the first tombs in the game big tombs
are back like big physics-based puzzle
laid in tombs and we spend I think it
was maybe like 20 or so minutes in it
and there's a lot of they've sort of
built the tutorial into the environment
so it'll give you like a small situation
like you need to learn to flutter room
to get Laura to a higher platform and
they present it to you in like little
bit so by the time you're towards the
end of the tomb and things are more
difficult you sort of know oh like I
look four walls that look like this and
then I can use this and it was just like
it's beautiful I hope those tools in
your arsenal to create something that's
more complex in the way that like many
good sort of puzzle solving kind of
situations are and it's great to hear
that yeah those tombs are big I think
that's been one of the bigger focuses
certainly of their PR campaign for rise
of the Tomb Raider is yeah yeah guys are
back in a big way members I think we all
remember the disappointment of walking
into a secret cave and having it say
optional tomb nobody wants an optional
to I'm a tomb raider and they said that
was a huge part that they wanted to fix
in this one so yeah tombs are not really
optional anymore this is about this is
about exploration and finding out and
discovery
because of the next-gen they can make
the tombs bigger I believe they've
claimed that there are three times they
can make three times the size and with
that as you're saying Chris more secrets
so tomb raiders known for these secrets
in the revamped they kind of changed the
word secret literally you'd find this
little shiny object in tomb Raider's
right and it would say you found a
secret I'd be like cool I don't know
what that is but it's a secret in this
one and the revamped Laura they've been
doing like a GPS has been of them and
just like little artifacts is another
one that you can find and they've done
that for this one as well so you will
find a sneaky little artifacts hidden
without the game and I believe they're
going to bring back GPS and other other
secrets within the area so there's more
to discover than than just finding out
what's in said tomb there's always
hidden pieces along the way yeah and
Laura's not going into that Laura's not
fighting for survival anymore so she's
sort of proactively running into this
adventure and throwing herself in danger
because she's I believe the story this
time is she's following her father's
research and looking for these secrets
in these two connected myths which I've
explained in a lovely primer on gamespot
com um and it's and you you get the
sense that she's not like you're not
trying to fight people off anymore
you're actively like running in and I
think that sort of proactivity and that
that it makes her very action focus like
you can see her becoming this is the
bottle part yeah like she's becoming
becoming the tomb raider yeah I know
that sounds cheesy and that's obviously
like the name of the game but I think
from what we saw you really you really
see it and you're really feeling it that
she's growing and she's maturing and
she's becoming this like savvy super
smart archaeologists and like super
physical prowess badass lady she's
coming into her own and I think there
was something to be said about the story
lacking a little bit in the first game I
am a huge fan of the series and stories
are never you know huge parts that like
knowing anyone ever believed that Laura
did backflips all the time every time
she jumped and killed the Tyrannosaurus
wix with two pistols yeah he's cool good
ladies this news this new way that
they've taken laura is very
realistic they want you to feel like
she's a real human being that has
feelings and emotions and she she goes
through some [ __ ] and sometimes she gets
stabbed through the belly that hurts and
it likes changes the way she can play
the game but the story in the first game
got a little obscure you didn't really
know why she was doing this or why she
was even exploring anything at all
because she was barely surviving she was
like struggling to live she wants to get
off that crazy Helen yeah place was
messed up and in this one it's not so
much that she's trying to survive she's
putting herself in dangerous scenarios
because she wants to know what's going
on she's starting to realize that she's
a very unique person she has all these
unique capabilities where she can take
down T Rexes with pistols and it's a
mistake for her to not put herself in
danger because she's one of a kind yeah
I think that they're selling that
character a lot better in this one she's
just a very unique person and she's
super badass and she will cut you action
hero Lara Croft rise of the Tomb Raider
coming out this year November 13th no
that's Europe we're gonna get November
10th even better sorry Europe all right
Alexa Mary thank you so much if you guys
want to know more about rise of the Tomb
Raider as election Alexa mentioned she's
got a big article about Laura up on the
site as well as a couple other videos
you can delve right into it and see a
lot more of what's in store for rise of
the Tomb Raider